[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
round seven of the norm Congress here in
st. Louis our top norm section saw both
leading ladies lose their games
grandmaster vorontsov cornered so lucky
do with a mate in one and addy Patel
showed how his Bishop and Knight
outmaneuvered Abraham Ian's rook Moran
Sava and Patel have first place but only
slightly in the international master
Norma ven met Senko is wrapping the
field up going +4 so far and beating
international master Torres in last
night's final evening round norms are
still within reach but only for those
who win the rest of their games round 8
coverage starts now players all over the
world have struggled to earn the
Grandmaster title which players will
earn a norm which players will go home
with the prize welcome to the 2018 st.
Louis norm Congress
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the penultimate round of the
2018 norm Congress I'm Ben Simon and
joined as always by Grandmaster Josh
Friedel we have games in progress here
in round eight but real quick let's not
waste any time take a look at the
results of what happened last night
in the tournament's final evening round
indeed lots of bloody games as we can
see John Bartholomew knocked out Akshay
Chandra pavlova on stove and Adi Patel
knocked out the two leaders as we saw in
the preview and mark Paraguay just
completely destroyed Hummel cool of so
the results the tournament results got
completely knocked around however I
would say it maximized everyone's
chances for norms going into the the day
there are still plenty of those and
we'll talk about that in a moment
as far as the other side of the room
last night round seven of the
International Master Norman field
these guys don't pack down that's all I
have to say yeah just a lot of crazy
games again a lot of the games really
could have been gone either way
but in the end we saw Matt saenko
securing his lead with the win over
Torres Torres that was actually his
third loss in a row week at the we call
it long castling it's but it's never a
fun thing so he's got to bounce back but
my tank was finally showing look guys
I'm Way higher than the rest of you I'm
the better player however it has not
been smooth sailing and anything can
happen as we know but for now he does
have the point now athlete and now with
just two rounds remaining and really
just one and a half and think about it
let's take a look at the standings we
can really start to break this down and
look at our true contenders the norm
standings after seven rounds yeah and as
you can see Varun 7 patel by beating two
lucky Joe and Abraham Ian took that lead
but both top-ten ansarullah art in the
chasing pack of fours along with Parag
WA and John Bartholomew and Patel and
Todd
and stab Rula they can all still norm in
this field they just have to win their
last two rounds okay and as far as the
International Master norm field after
seven okay it's not so close at the top
anymore job no it certainly isn't you
have met Cinco leading with 5.5 now in a
normal tournament you'd say okay his
odds of not winning the event are really
tiny he has an advantage of this game I
think it's likely he'll secured his
first place however the great thing
about a Norman you have all these
players still playing for something big
and to be honest for most players the
norm is more important even than scoring
first in the tournament so you see all
those people with four if they win if
any of them win two of their games they
get an International Master norm
obviously doesn't mean so much for Joe
Bonanno who already has the title but
for Corbin ski Stearman turgut and call
us they can secure that norm with two
wins in the final rounds couldn't have
said it better now the games in progress
right now let's take a look at the Grand
Master norm field in round eight indeed
so you have some major matchups my game
of the day at least would be so lucky to
against Parag WA but plenty of nice
matchups Daniel Gurevich already
defeated Akshay Chandra as black if you
guys remember ger Davis isn't having a
rough event but you can never
underestimate anyone in this field and
he knocked out Chandra pretty simply I
would say all right and we have a game
of the day there for our GM North Field
yes indeed so lucky do and Mark prologue
WA indeed a really exciting game
I think Parag WA took the advantage
maybe from store most of rulers hands
because I thought that she actually had
a very promising position earlier but
we'll get to that game I look forward to
seeing it and then the International
mastered norm field in round eight
what's happening at this moment at us
chess champ STATCOM indeed so as far as
results go Justin wing already defeated
Jobin our young Justin getting back into
the hunt not in norm contention but can
certainly have a good result
that's definitely disappointing for Joel
who can no longer win the tournament but
obviously good results still possible
and I believe the rest of the games are
going except Josh colas did defeat
canceled
so Josh still has no chances and he wins
his last round target is out indeed
so I mean that was the game we were
going to talk about in the international
master dorm section we still have to
look at that okay real quick the
tournament format to attend player
around Robin fields game in 90 with a 30
second increment from move 1 and here's
an important addition now that we start
thinking about it I've been told by the
arbiters there will be no playoffs so if
if the players are tied for first at the
end we will just have co-winners indeed
and it seems to lack excitement quite
honestly after a tournament like this
two games a day those players are pretty
relieved not to have to play some
playoffs I can tell you that yeah this
tournament is more about the individual
right can I achieve the norm maybe not
being 1st place is the most important
although exactly but I can tell you it's
still nice to get that first place
especially if you're not one of the norm
seekers but even if you are you can get
a norm and square that first place
that's a good day we've been going at it
for three hours already this even though
this broadcast just started let's take a
look at the schedule 11:00 a.m. was when
the game started today for the
penultimate round and tomorrow is our
finale it also starts at 11 a.m. Central
time we go on the air at 2 p.m. at us
chess champs dot-com okay
so Josh let's take a look at some of the
games before everything really goes
crazy yes I'm gonna quickly take you
through the games that are completed so
this game was except Ronda lost against
then you'll go to image this is an
important moment he has that this I'd
say Black has done really nice position
Oxshott has this deep Lombok aidid but
he plays Bishop f1 trying to attack that
pawn and gritch says you know what I'm
gonna keep advancing it's my past pawn I
want to keep going at it and Akshay
doesn't believe him he's like alright
buddy I'll take that guy but with this
many pins this many tactics Bishop f5 is
in the air this is very dangerous so
gray [ __ ] did something very clever he
played b5 now threatening to just simply
take that c4 pawn Oxshott takes back
rook d5 massive pin on the D file rookie
3
you have five that's just way too many
pieces attacking that bishop when after
three or four pieces and I think that
here it's basically over I don't know
what actua missed but my guess would be
that he missed maybe be five to be
honest though it looked like a pretty
tough position anyway he takes on f5 and
Gritty of it just finishes by not taking
the Queen which would be a little bit
less clear but taking that rook check
and the idea of course is that if Queen
takes Queen rook takes check take the
bishop you're up a whole rook for two
pawns not no chance at this level so a
nice win for Daniel who's been
struggling but tough loss for Akshay
he actually might be in last place now
but definitely not a good result for him
otherwise Josh colas as we mentioned
defeated tencel target as white this
game was quite a crazy game I thought
that out of the opening around here
tencel had an excellent position and he
built up what I thought was a very nice
advantage he just controlled all the
squares
he has like that past pawn on d4
controls all the dark squares I thought
that Josh was gonna be in for long
suffering however tencel got a little
bit careless he played this move Bishop
a3 which looks nice if you trade off
these bishops these dark squares are
just super tasty but here Josh found the
nice shot
c5 this is why you always have to keep a
tactical lookout look for all your tempo
moves anything that attacks something
now you have a bishop attacked you of a
knight attack and a pawn attacked that's
too many pieces and he tries taking on
be too but after Bishop takes a6 hitting
the rook the bishops hanging the pawns
hanging it's just too much plays Bishop
a3 snag that rook and from here it was
only a matter of time until Josh reeled
on the point he snuck in an h-file I
thought tencel was getting a little bit
of counter play here but quite honestly
it's too much in this position it's
already pretty hopeless potential
blunders by with this move Josh wraps up
the game nicely I'm not sure this was
necessary but he plays rook h8
threatening rook 1 to h7 meat that is a
tough threat to stop yeah I think it's
impossible to stop it most certainly
okay good
I was legitimately trying to figure that
out I was
to be smart with you are you sure I
don't know I I sense sarcasm you know
how cookie yeah of course and the other
game was Justin weighing defeated
Okinawa he traded to a queen in game he
did something kind of clever he
surrounded his king with his pawns that
King is unassailable you get a passed
pawn which is more important almost than
having extra pawns in a queen and
pawning game Justin says take all the
pawns you want I'm gonna Queen my a pawn
and sure enough maybe Joe could have
defended slightly better but to be
honest this is just hopeless and he
resigned here the idea is if pawn takes
pawn Queen takes pawn the Queen has to
stop this a pawn of course and now he
simply plays back note how the Queen
beautifully guards the king and you're
threatening this you can't perpetual you
can't stop so anyways so he actually
resigned in this position so uh let us
see what game should we start with so we
have a turgut and but now what now
officially out of the running for first
you know yeah I am the one field and and
also out of the norm
although but in a bonala wasn't in the
search for him but turbot was yes why
don't we take a look at the stuff ruler
against mark Paraguay again so we have
this position
this was quite a crazy game let's take a
look at how this occurred it was a it
was a an anti Berlin took on c6 very
typical so now you almost have an
exchange Roy type structure the idea is
that this e pawn is annoying to defend
you play rook yeats
ninety seven castles Queen side a lot of
people like the Castle kingside you get
a more positional game stavroula as
we've seen this tournament an aggressive
player she wants to go for the throat
she's like rook g1 not very subtle Ben
she wants to shove that Jeep on b5 a5g4
and here I have no idea what's going on
perfectly honest with you guys but she's
on the attack here
I thought White's position looked
promising just because I wasn't sure
these pawns are really going much of
anywhere so but this happened however
somehow she got a little bit stuck mark
played a3 which is an interesting move B
3 and then Queen f6 and as you guys can
see this Knight is effectively pinned
because you can't allow me I thought she
might try Knight c4 with idea that if
you try to attack this Knight e5 and you
close down this diagonal however it's
understandable not to want to play this
move e5 because the problem with e5 is
that it does break up your pawns it
gives black a few squares like f5 and d5
I don't know but after Bishop c1 also
covering the mate he plays Knight f4 and
now this Queen just has no we're good to
go and this Knight is also attacked
which could be a problem so she gives up
her bishop but quite honestly I do not
like her position when she gives that
bishop up even if she ends up up upon
the two bishops this King is a little
bit weak
I'm just not such a fan and she actually
trades Queens here which you think would
be a good thing she does snag that G
pawn
however these Knights they may defend
each other but Knights defending each
other are often actually quite
vulnerable because if you attack both of
them neither Knight can move so they're
almost paralyzed they defend each other
they do a good job but they can never
move and that's usually a bad sign for
those nights I would say that at least
at least from a dynamic point of view I
think that black has lots of
possibilities however the ruler is up
that one pawn maybe it'll come through
she plays h4 I'm guessing trying to play
h5 and weaken the King side he plays
rook out for rook back to g3 keeping an
eye on that night it should be six she
grabs another pawn why not doubles rooks
be five so I don't know it's one of
those positions where it could be really
really dangerous for whites but at the
same time if she can consolidate somehow
if she can trade off one of those
bishops if she can win some material you
never really know it's still a very
dynamic position very interesting and I
definitely look forward to following
this game so I guess the real question
here is what is what is Mark gonna do
after the obvious capture of the night I
think stabbed ruler will take and then
probably take this bishop note how 94 is
often a threat here so if you recapture
you have to watch out maybe you couldn't
get away with it anyway maybe I would
start with rook h3 though threatening a
very subtle mate I assume she would not
want to allow that and then recaptures
but here she could take on before and
even though this pawn on a3 is kind of
annoying that's just too many pawns
probably you might take on h4 it's still
an unclear situation but quite honestly
I think that this is not quite what mark
wants so my guess would be after E 5
he'll try to find another solution maybe
he'll try Bishop c5 the idea of course
is that now you're still hitting this
Knight and maybe why could try d4 here
and I guess the problem is that you know
what do you do with your bishop if you
allow too much this night can also come
to g5 now takes the knight as possible
rook takes rook rook takes pawn takes
but even here this pawn is still a
weakness the main threat won't last
forever if you play rook h3 even if I
have to play King c1 or rook d1 it still
looks like why it's doing reasonably so
it could be that mark actually already
is having a few problems here after
Bishop c5 g4 maybe he can try moving
again keeping that Bishop but now he's
not guarding this pawn anymore Knight g5
is indeed with tempo on the bishop it's
actually just not so simple so it could
be that already it's not so easy and in
fact Bishop c5 was played so we'll see
what's triple the place she could play
d4 maybe 95 but 95 Bishop d5 it feels
like there are too many knights attacked
here I'm not a huge fan but you never
know it's all very tactical so I'd have
to sit down myself and calculate 5 10 15
minutes to figure everything out I'm
gonna let these players do the work
right I don't have to stavroula look at
the time here 30 seconds 30 seconds if
those times are accurate she has a rough
go because again I would like to spend
15 minutes whatever it is it looks like
she did in fact play d4 you can see her
on the screen
and Mark I would say is a little bit
quicker and he also is used to playing
more rapidly so he actually did play a
bishop back to b6 d4 Bishop back to b6
so I expect Knight g5 here from her not
a lot of time but still still should be
enough and again I think that he may be
miss messed up because honestly it looks
like she's taking too much you know say
after a remove like 9 g5 which was in
fact played I suspect Bishop d5 maybe
Bishop d7 is more accurate so the bishop
doesn't get attacked actually ah he
plays to f5 he doesn't even want to
attack that night so yeah this is kind
of a tricky move again before Hanks but
so does d4 so for example if you play
Knight takes here his plan might just be
to take on d4 with the bishop and those
bishops are pretty powerful if he can
maintain those pieces it's pretty good
one of the ideas for example is if 95
you can play rook takes f2 and ideas you
still can't take this bishop because of
the stupid mate with rook F one mate is
always a problem
so if rook takes rook Bishop takes rook
again maybe she can try rook c3 play
dynamic but honestly with the back rake
as weak as it is I would be kind of
nervous here especially with no time but
keep in mind if she can get that rook
into c7 she might be actually someone
playing for mates so he would actually
have to be a little careful maybe play C
flat but this is quite far afield in the
game she played Knight to e7 rather than
take this B pawn she tries to go after
the bishop maybe she wants this little
knight fork here I'm not exactly sure to
be honest I preferred taking the pawn at
least I did glance just to eliminate
that guy from the board allow her to
free up this King side a little bit but
my guess would be she really wants to
take one of those bishops so this game
is quite exciting she doesn't have much
time left there let's see what he played
he looks like he just played a move rook
takes h4 indeed he takes off the pawn
keep in mind rook h1 is a threat so he's
got she's got to deal with that my guess
would be she takes on f5 but
I'm not exactly sure she's got to do it
fast though otherwise bad things will
happen
yeah gosh this is tough 30 seconds added
per move but still that's but you got to
think you sometimes you know and it's
just practically speaking it's such a
tough situation to be in and again maybe
you know she's resourceful maybe she'll
do something it looks like she played
rook to g1 she did not take this bishop
so she guards against the maid threat
but again it's it's just a tough
situation
d4 hangs as well my guess would be
though that she has a trick in mind this
is the reason she played 97 is let's say
if Bishop takes d4 she can now play even
rook takes d4 as a move the idea being
that after rook takes Knight takes f5
check for King the king and queen and
after rook takes guess what fork number
to take the rook so that's a really nice
trick my guess would be this was her
idea when she played it keep in mind
even without with little time players
this strong see lots of tactics don't
get me wrong so it's just because she is
low on time does not mean she doesn't
have tricks up her sleeve this is
probably why she did not take the B pawn
which is what I wanted to do but but
we'll see it I'm sure marks not gonna
fall for it the question is what does he
have to do this bishop actually doesn't
have that many squares
however these Knights are can be a
little bit stranded in some position so
if you if he finds a way to put that
Bishop on a C F square she might find
that her Knights are a little bit
awkward but quite a game definitely will
try to keep an eye on it I mean it's
very important for the standings in this
section
it certainly is it's not only important
for the standings it's important for
norris's Tallulah needs two out of two
to get her norm and parag WA is tied
with her meaning that he obviously
doesn't need a norm he's already a
grandmaster but if he gets a win here
he'll have a shot to play for first
place if he loses almost for sure first
places out of reach now there are three
players in both fields at this time who
can earn their norm for the Grandmaster
title or the I M title and they all have
to win both of their games yeah it's
very simple guys actually this event
because no one's on pace to get a norm
what
mean by that as no one is if they
continue their current rate they'll get
a norm but there are several players
within reach of the norm meaning that if
they win out if they crush their last
two games they get they get their norms
so we see a kind of a sightings internet
scenario and a nice one just because
it's easy for us we know that if you
don't win you're both of your games
you're not getting your norm so it could
be no one gets a norm it could be you
see a cup two or three people get a norm
probably not more than that but still an
exciting finish and it just makes these
games all the more interesting to watch
because they're not just playing for
first they're playing for they're their
norm towards the GM title and let me
tell you those things are valuable so
why don't we find another game we'll
definitely keep an eye on this one
let us see so speaking of standings this
game between josiah Stearman and satyr
game at cinco is important for the
standards basically if Matt Cinco scores
a win here he pretty much he secures
first place no one can catch him
guarantee and Stearman would lose his
shot at an IM norm because Thurman needs
to win out to score his norm it looks
like he will not win out it looks like
to me black is winning see this knight
on e4 that guy is very strong Black has
the bad bishop no no all the pawns are
on light squares meaning that's over
yeah he just resigns it this is hopeless
the point is all the pawns are in light
squares are in dark squares sorry
all blacks pawns are in light squares
meaning the bishop can never attack them
but here the problem is actually much
simpler than that let's say white ways
to move with Bishop c7 black plays King
h3 this pawn is just gonna run up so for
example if King here pawn here King here
pawn here the night maneuvers its way to
f3 g2 that is gonna be all she wrote so
Josiah gave in Sergey secures first
place in his event he still has not
really looked completely dominating he's
at a couple games where he actually
should have lost but one of the features
of really strong players is they don't
give up they don't you know they keep
the game going when they're in
and they give themselves the maximum
chances they didn't put him away he put
away the games he needed to and that's
why he's won this event indeed we'd like
to congratulate Sergey Mexico on being
the champion of the International Master
norm section here at the norm Congress
you have to talk to him we certainly
would like to talk to him again
you're 2560 you expect to win but it's
not always that simple there are so many
things that can go wrong in an
individual game in a tournament so that
he locked it up when I'm around ago I'm
sure he'll be happy with and we'll see
what else goes on so why don't we get
back to this game I don't think I can
take this game to be perfectly honest
mr. berola having almost no time mark
having about 15 not 10 minutes now so
he's also gonna get low
very good rapid players so I don't think
he's worried about it but at the same
time it's always rough he did what I
thought he'd try keep both bishops on
the board if you give up a bishop you
lose a lot of dynamic potential meaning
that it's harder to attack lots of
things that's harder to really have your
position flow have those bishops really
be strong so he wants to keep those
pieces on the board to give himself
maximum dynamic potential not to mention
the practical feature of making it
harder for stuff Rula to not wonder it
sounds like a simple thing but quite
honestly when it's when you're low on
time not blundering is half the battle
if you can manage not to blunder when
you're low you give yourself chances so
she played 95 she wants one of those
bishops real bad so he played rook f5
and she plays f4 so she cuts off this
rook effectively this night however I
would not say isn't exactly a stable
piece so maybe she should be a little
worried but honestly this is a tricky
position because the knight the bishops
might be strong in theory but right now
these Knights are a menace at the moment
for example this bishop is always
attacked so c6 is not playable if I move
like Bishop c6 you might even say hello
Knight Fork I can tell you when you're
low on time facing Knights is a huge
pain because for some reason missing a
knight fork is a very easy thing to do
compared to missing other types of
attacks I don't know why just the way
the human brain is
wired so this is just one of those times
where you know flip the script here the
nights might be worth more than the
bishop pair it is very possible and a
lot of it's because she is up upon here
that definitely helps her cause but it's
also because those nights are good and I
have to say she's playing very well
really holding this together despite
having no time not an easy thing she may
make it look easy but this is very
difficult to play and I would say it's
difficult to play for both sides this is
not a one-sided thing so again he has to
find a way to destabilize these Knights
right now these Knights are just sitting
on the board they're happy they're
getting fat they're ready to take some
pawns he's got to find a way to make
those Knights less stable but it's
easier said than done you play a move
like h6 which looks like a reasonable
try now if the knight moves back here
and you attack it this Knight doesn't
have that many happy squares but maybe
she'll just move back to e4 keep in mind
this Bishop can always be captured this
night might go here after you capture
the bishop the knight might go here
attacking this bishop this guy might
become a weakness at some point for
example and move like 97 might become
relly nasty I know that's too many
arrows I apologize if that's not to
confuse you but say he plays okay this
move I get no one's gonna put their
Bishop on 85 this moves ridiculous bear
with me I just want to illustrate this
might be quite nasty the idea being this
pawn is now under attack
of course rook takes rook takes here as
possible and after here forking the
rooks you actually have this so in this
particular position it doesn't work but
just illustrating as a point what can
happen when you have these pieces he
actually went to a7 and she said thank
you very much another illustration of
those Knight forks because if f4 gets
captured for Conny six and if you take
the knight it simply gets replaced and
its replacement will take this rook this
is dead loss of course I don't expect
him to do this however that's two pawns
that's our two connected pawns and if
she manages to keep her position stable
keep those Knights hop and keep those
pawns rolling I think she's gonna come
away with the win it really is and I
have to say at the beginning of this
endgame I did not think highly of her
position I thought that the Knights were
unstable
I thought the bishop should win and
maybe my judgment was off but it could
also be that he overestimated his
position
and he played a careless mover - and let
her back in quite possibly I agree with
you when we first saw the position cuz I
was like oh yeah
but she's found a way to turn it around
and quite honestly I think sometimes
when people have an opponent who's low
on time they sometimes play carelessly
themselves they expect errors and when
those errors don't pop up when those
errors don't occur they actually
decrease the standard of their own play
and that's a very dangerous thing to do
so when your opponent's low on time it's
important that you kind of forget it and
just try to play good moves yourself I'm
not saying that's what happened to him
obviously these are all pros but it
cannot really happen to anyone but right
now I'd say stir rule is looking for the
win which might catapult her towards the
lead again and keep her in the running
for her Jam
yes very impressive and you'll notice
paraguas time is coming down when we
first took a look at this game he was at
13 minutes I believe that ruler was
essentially one minute so yeah but this
might be quite equal in the time
Department soon believe it or not yeah
and considering where we were that is uh
that would be quite something he did in
fact play h6 in this position and now
it's just a matter of where she wants to
move the night I would imagine she would
play 96 check just to gain a game that
tempo but who knows after 96 checks she
could be worried about king f7 and those
nights need a home after 90 th a king
here those nights are just hopping but
they need a place to settle down and it
doesn't look like it might happen
however after maybe 7:00 the really
funny thing is this there's still a fork
so you can't take on f4 even here and
those nights are actually more stable
than they appear so I don't know this is
obviously far-fetched but it could
happen and I think she might check on e6
just because she needs that tempo if she
moves the night elsewhere f4 is hanging
so we'll see how that goes
other games I feel like I should mention
pavlovo also of his black in this game
against Danish Burroughs he is one of
the leaders I suspect that he will win
this game so Danish just played c4 this
is an important moment one of the
problems is if black takes here
immediately this mate win but it allows
a rook
and then king blocking this pawn and
that's a crucial tactic because now this
rook is free to roam it can attack this
pawn it can attack this pawn and the
game becomes far more complicated maybe
you're still winning
I suspect however and notice by the way
that if white ever takes this pawn for
example if white just captured you enter
this King and pawn endgame the black is
far in the lead you're gonna just
capture these ponds it's gonna be pretty
much over so this is not an option
however let's say black says okay I'll
pass
what is white play here let's say King
to b3 looks like a logical move right
but now I take on h5 and the problem is
that if you give a check and I go here
you must go back in order to prevent
this if you try King b2 I simply say
I'll take a queen please trade off your
rook and we're back in the same
situation winning King and pawn in game
so he would actually after King takes h5
he would have to play back to be two now
you can play King g4 you can still play
this move but after King takes f4 King
takes up five I'm guessing that's just
too many pawns and note how it's a key
tempo game with this sneaky little move
rook a seven I would suspect he'll play
row k 7r okay six waste that temple but
in this case wasting the temple actually
gains a temple yeah quite an important
pop over on service threatening to
increase his lead here in the top spot
with the Grandmaster norm section indeed
and it looks like he might have to cuz
if the ruler comes away with the wind
she's gonna be chasing so he'll need the
wind to stay half a point ahead of her
however or Adi Patel the other leader is
also someone to keep an eye on he is now
playing John Bartholomew they are here
so Adi is up in exchange
well this King I would be worrying about
missing a background check made here to
be honest however John's trying to make
kind of play against the black King he's
trying to create some threats if blacks
not careful black could end up
checkmated here but I think with best
play probably addi should actually come
away with the win - which would mean
we'd actually
two people still leading and stavroula
would have to win just to stay within
touching distance for first place never
mind
simply the norm but it's still very
complicated it's one of those positions
where anything had happened
John is only down to a minute and a half
so he's got to play super fast Addie has
five minutes as we're seeing in all
these games time is a huge factor and it
basically makes the game more random
because some people will miss stuff some
people will not miss stuff and one
blunder can kind of cost you the game
regardless of how good your position is
one blunder often just means the end
even if you're a better to start with so
we're kind of seeing that now I suspect
Addie should be winning maybe but it's
just there are so many things that can
go wrong for you in positions like this
and Addie plays G 5 not exactly a pretty
move but the idea is that he wants to
make sure that Queen stays out of the
game the Queen probably has to retreat
you have to keep this square covered
even a move like f6 as possible it
doesn't look pretty but it keeps white
at bay for the moment and again that
extra exchange probably the rook will
come over try to penetrate the white
position I think the extra exchange
should probably do it but it's still a
long way to go before he can ever claim
a win here this is still massively
complicated so I guess we should jump
back this to ruler game should have an
eye on it just because no one has any
time
so yeah the Knights are hippity hopping
around the board Knight g6 check has
mentioned king of seven she doesn't
choose my knight da check to be seven
maneuver probably cuz it looks
ridiculous
she chose 95 also hitting the bishop if
it gets captured the bishops still
attacked important feature so he opts
for Bishop c6 and she plays Knight a6 so
she is sacrificing this pawn but she's
also attacking this one so it's kind of
a trade off for example if rook takes f4
pretty sure she's gonna grab this pawn
and it's a tricky position it looks like
there should be a tactic but I don't see
anything that works first of all if rook
f1 check she simply she does not take
and get made it
she will instead play rook d1 and
everything's kind of covered the rooks
defend each other very nicely
and things seem covered if after Knight
takes before try he tries this which
looks like it's a killer because if pawn
takes Bishop the night falls you can
take the other bishop and this is why
Knights are so tricky there are always
things to take and this Knight
conveniently guards both these pawns if
look back you can still go here I would
suspect that this is a winning position
so it's really up to mark to find
another solution if indeed there is one
but if he doesn't take this F pawn I
have no clue what he's actually doing
maybe he can try another Bishop move but
I think that she's gonna take on before
no matter what so it still looks quite
promising but again low on time anything
truly can happen there any gave us up we
haven't taken a look at yet that are
close to finishing up ah let us see so
that game finished this one finished yes
I think this game between grab insky and
Torres is quite interesting I don't know
how close it is to finishing but it's
certainly pretty nuts at the moment I
kind of like Torres this position simply
because I think that this pawn and the
rook coming down is gonna be really
tough to stop White has a pawn also this
e6 pawn looks nasty but the problem is
you need a way to force it through so
for example after six this Bishop still
kind of covers it might be pinned but
it's not really pinned because there's
real good defended and if you have to
take the bishop it's just too much time
so I think you can even just play B to
say whatever do what you do your worst
if you give a check I play King h7 the
important thing is this is still covered
I just don't really see a way to force
that through or is this B pawn is just a
battering ram
it's just shattering White's position
you have to play route b1 rook c1 and
again I just think blacks too fast so it
looks to me like unless Aran can find a
really nice resource here he's probably
going to end up on the worst side of
things I'm not exactly sure if there's a
particular resource he could have here
but it just looks like he's not fast
enough so taurah is picking up a win
which is an important result for him
considering if you recall he long castle
lost three games in a row
and it's always brutal to try to recover
from that so it says a lot about him
that he's able to play such a nice game
and defeat a strong player after losing
three in a row well in urban ski
unfortunately for him we'll miss out on
his norm how much frustration do you
feel like a player to go through an
experience coming to a specific Norma
tournament and at least having the
possibility this far in and then losing
the possibility it really bears on the
player some players really tie
themselves into these Norma's ult's so
if they miss that one game they missed
that one result they get especially
upset others are kind of like it'll
happen when it happens I'm gonna be
strong enough especially about players
going up the ranks getting 224 2500 they
know they're gonna get there they don't
care so much but it's always a bit of a
wound I would say it's less so when you
need to a tattoo that feels like a lot
if you need to score perfect it doesn't
feel like you're that close yet you know
it's one thing if you need to win in
that last round but if you have to go -
out of - that's a tough result for
anyone to to do so I wasn't exactly
something you would play for a win
versus a safe draw uh I mean I would say
that you want out you always try to keep
your chances open you would you wouldn't
go crazy some people do but for the most
part you're not gonna go crazy but what
I would say is that you keep your
options open you're trying to make it so
you can still snap that norm but I would
say that's it when it's - out of - it's
tough but when it's you need like one
out of two or you need one and a half a
tattoo like a score that seems at least
more obtainable and you miss out those
are the ones that hurt especially if
it's that last time especially if it's
some crucial situation that those are
the ones that are painful but as far as
for Aaron I mean you know needing two
out of two playing to strong players
that's that's a tough ask and I'm sure
we'll be disappointed but you know it's
more understandable and indeed this did
happen east 6b2 happened
Brooks headed back to be one rook see
ones coming I think that i think that
Louise is gonna take care of this one so
let's see I know we have a particular
guest in the city who might be
interviewed fairly soon Oh indeed you
have executive director of the Chess
Club
Tony rich is at this table will be
asking
about the upcoming grand chest tour the
US Championship and of course this
tournament indeed should be fun
interview another result by the way a
pavlova runs up did beat Danish Mirage
so he maintains the lead will at least
be tied for the lead adi Patel's only
one who can catch him this round with a
win so yeah it pretty much happened the
way I suspected he played rook a 5
instead of Brookhaven I guess that was a
pretty weird-looking move I was just
trying to be fancy and Danish and said
tried to activate the King but quite
honestly you're essentially playing down
this rook it's kind of tough to do
anything so he simply goes around with
his king the idea here is if white
continues to follow he could play a move
like rook a3 like Adam moves the rook
can never move this pawn would just get
captured so the King would have to move
this King comes in pretty much dead so
he tried King D for King f3
you could try to play for a stalemate
but it seems kind of unlikely as
considering this pawn can always move
rook f1 check King e2 King d2 so he
again he's just running out of moves
very slowly if king e4 King c3 so Denish
tries to sack his pawn but there's
nothing to do
King b2 comes next time to throw in the
towel yeah he's had a pretty rough event
he hadn't really nice win against top
that actually in the first round I
thought he played very well but since
then he struggled a bit but it's a rough
tournament it's one of those things
where if you're not on Form if you're
not watching at all your games I mean
you can lose to anyone in the event it's
not an event it's not like a Swiss where
you lose a couple games you have a bad
event but then you play some much weaker
players you get your confidence back
round robins you do not have that luxury
it could be quite brutal it can be very
brutal I can tell you from past
experience believe me so let me see if
there are any results in I'm not seeing
anything yeah seems like everything's
still going so well perhaps this would
be a good time to take our first break
and when we come back we will have the
executive director of the st. Louis
chess club internacional arbiter Tony
rich he'll be joining us talking about
the upcoming grand chest tour 2018
and the US Championship so we'll be back
here at us chest champs calm in just a
few moments question on Twitter from dem
s I should not have pronounced that that
was a bit of a champion for those of you
who are new to chess it might look like
ba 3 is an illegal move here because
white advances pawn to square is not one
but it still is something we call a song
and you can do that I have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move
I'd say play King in seven kimchi - and
I'll try because y'all played four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed the playing during the course
of my steak yeah he told me this is
excellent g5 this was what I was kind of
hoping for because now I think we
practiced I know who Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if Chester G
to work like this I don't think it does
well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me
and what's worse I will never hear the
end of it my quality of life has just
gone downhill tremendously because I'm
actually sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to the
broadcast for the 2018 st. Louis norm
Congress I'm Ben Simon along with my
very special guest at this time he is
the executive director of the st. Louis
chess club international arbiter Tony
rich Tony thank you for joining me
thanks for having me Ben and he is the
deputy arbiter for this event as well
how is the tournament going so far in
your perspective you know what's going
well so far the players seem to all be
enjoying themselves one of the things
that we always say before either a norm
tournament or the classics or even US
Championships is I want this to be the
best event you've ever played in now
it's hard to make that happen every
single time but we work hard to make
that the case whether it's the
temperature in the room or the lighting
or the food that's available for the
players we work hard to make them all
enjoy themselves and I think they are
now we know that these kinds of
tournaments aren't too common where
specifically everybody who doesn't
already have the title can earn a norm
what is why is the Chess Club going to
such lengths to put such events together
it's a great question you know it's
funny
st. Louis chess up until maybe a couple
of years ago suffered from the same
problem that norm participants suffer
from and that's when you're trying to
find an event for players rated
somewhere between 22 and 2600 let's say
it's really difficult you know all of
the the organizers with the big bucks
want to invite Magnus Carlsen and akaru
Nakamura and all the players although
the organizers who are doing it on a
volunteer effort have a hard time
raising the kind of prize funds and
conditions available for players
so for us we saw this as kind of a sweet
spot something that didn't really exist
in chess or was maybe lacking a little
bit and we saw it as an opportunity to
grow chess in America and I think it's
working well and Josh and I were talking
before in this chart everybo about how a
lot of these players were seen for the
first time and maybe a few years from
now who knows you know they might be
some of the elite
I remember our early Normans whenever it
was players like Robert Haas and Jeffrey
Zhang and Sam Shanklin and I look at
them I mean these are all veteran
grandmasters if you can call them that
but you know they represent the us on
the Olympia teams they play in the US
Championship every year so you see a lot
of strong players come out of this and
it's a chance for us to get to know them
whenever they're still improving and
coming up there's an another strong
tournament that maybe everyone won't be
familiar with the entire field but I'm
talking about the spring chess Classic
the next one in the seasonal series of
tournaments tell us about the spring
Classic sure yeah you should mention the
spring Classic is one of four
tournaments it's a seasonal event we
hold it in the spring summer fall and
winter two sections ten player round
robins kind of similar to this but we're
really up the game the top section
average rating is something like twenty
six fifty typically the lower section
average rating is about twenty five
fifty and for the most part I think all
of the players have been GM's
that have competed in the event maybe a
couple of exceptions here and there so
the the classic series provide us with
an opportunity for a few things one we
can provide training opportunities for
young up-and-coming players American or
otherwise we can provide training
opportunities for the women in chess in
America think US women's championship
field kind of players and another
opportunity is for the collegiate level
players to also have a chance to test
their mettle against their peers so the
spring chess classic actually is coming
up it's March 6 through the 14th prize
fund for that will be thirty two
thousand dollars combined between the
two sections we have some pretty
big-name players across the events Alix
ona shook in Lazzaro bruise on will lead
our top section both with a ver with
ratings of almost 2700 in our lower
section Alexander fear from Brazil and
Victor mikhalev ski from Israel will be
competing so you know the fields are
really super competitive super strong
and I like this you know if you lose one
game you're not necessarily going to get
an easy pairing the next round for sure
and we will be broadcasting that
tournament by the way that's right u.s.
chess champs calm so very exciting stuff
and I look very much looking forward to
that so beyond the spring Classic the
chess club's original love the US Chess
Championship what can you tell us about
the US Championship this year and the
Women's Championship of course sure it's
our 10th year first of all hosting both
events it's also the 10th year that the
Chess Club and scholastic Center has
been open so it's a real milestone for
us it's an opportunity to bring back all
of those
great players that that we consider our
extended chess family you know once a
year they all come back to st. Louis and
hang out with us for a while so that's
great
the u.s. championship in the Women's
Championship you can expect a lot this
year first of all the event is April
16th through the 30th we'll have live
commentary on US chess champs calm as
well total prize fund combined for the
events is almost three hundred thousand
dollars my goodness fifty thousand for
the first-place winner of the
championship 25 thousand for first place
in the US women's championship and it'll
be interesting to see if these players
are gonna bring what they brought last
year and I'm sure you remember that
Wesley so on the US Championship and
Sabina fuller won the US Women's
Championship so both will be competing
again in their respective fields Wesley
has two best out Hikaru Nakamura and
other strong players like Fabiano
Caruana I mean top 10 players in the
world sabina still has her arch rivals
that have been in the perennial US
women's champions Irina cross and
Hannah's a Tomsky so it'll be very
competitive very tough event and we're
looking forward to it again yeah in this
US Championship I mean it's always been
a strong event but the US Championship
now compared to like ten years ago is
simply a different beast it really as
part of that has to do with the size of
the field when America's foundation for
chess ran the event you know they had
very large format 32 64 players
sometimes that brings down the average
rating in fact our first year holding
the event was a 24 players Swiss so the
average rating does drop a little bit
but whenever you have these 12 players I
mean it really is the who's who of
American chess and then after the US
Championship we can all get excited
about the fourth grand chest tour that's
right so the grand chest tour is
accommodation of Paris Leuven London and
then the to st. Louis tournaments which
is what we're really looking forward to
and so tell us first about there's a
little bit of a switch up this year with
the to st. Louis tournaments that's
right in fact there are two switch ups
last year Paris came before Leuven this
year it'll be reversed Leuven comes
before Paris and then st. Louis rapid
and blitz will come before the C field
Cup so the idea is that over the course
of the the year players will compete
across the three rapid and blitz events
then they'll play the classic event of
the same field cup now at the end of all
of that we'll take the top four players
combined scores from all four
vents and they will play in London at
the end of the year for the capstone the
postseason of the grand chessboard
so that format will be a four player
knockout and it will feature a
combination of rabbit and blitz and
maybe even classic games - I love that I
love that there's a grand finale a
knockout for like a true champion you
know it represents somebody from running
away with the event early on you know if
magnus carlsen has a fantastic result in
the first three events he's gonna be
really really hard to catch by the time
you make it to London the way this works
is the four players that are finishing
up after the Sinquefield Cup whichever
four qualify for London the slates
arranged now they start from from zero
again and it's just me versus you mano a
mano all right and I'm not sure if we
already showed it on the screen but the
Sinquefield come you know the the Chess
Club strongest tournament ever
traditionally and with the what is this
the sixth year now for the Sinquefield
come that's right I remember our very
first year whenever it was just four
players Magnus Carlsen and Levon Aronian
against Hikaru Nakamura and can you name
the fourth got a caps key got a campus
that's right so you know the grand chest
tour kind of revamped the scene filled
cup you know we went from four players
initially the following year was a six
player double round-robin and then we
settled into this ten player round-robin
format with the grand chester and it's
been impressive ever since for real okay
well Tony I appreciate you coming down
here from your busy schedule upstairs
and I'll let you get back to that thank
you very much thanks for having me and
let's go and check out the latest from
chess 24 one of our great partners at
u.s. chess champ Scott we when we come
back we will have more analysis
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership the
question on Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba three is an illegal
move here because white monsters point
to squares or one but it still is
something we call ultrasone and you can
do that I get to do it instantly you
can't wait for a move like let say clay
King in seven kimchi - and I'll try
because y'all played four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my steak
yeah he told me this is that d5 this was
what I was kind of hoping for because
now I think we finally know who Lawrence
this is not how it works certainly would
be much much more fun if Chester G to
work like this we don't think it does
well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation hello chess
fans Bensimon and grandmaster josh
Friedel back here for coverage of the
penultimate round eight of the norm
Congress and Josh we have a big result
we do ostrov ruler so lucky do remember
that Knights vs. bishops battle well she
traded those Knights in for lots of
hefty material and three massive pawns
as you can see in this position it is
basically over he tried to get those
pawns rolling she it looked like these
the rook it's tricky because the rooks
attacking but she had a really nice move
to end the game rook have to check they
do you mean the King has to walk into a
very unfortunate G line rook check if
the King moves to the side even if you
just play here it's just over the pawns
block these guys are just rolling off
the board and of course a bishop check
you can say check get a queen and this
is pretty much dead so after rook F to
check mark or science table Rula moves
up she is not in the lead however as
verano of defeated as the Verano of won
his game which means so he's still on
the half a point lead however still
ruler keeps her norm chances and chances
to finish first alive she has to win her
last round I'm assuming with the black
pieces actually against atif so it will
not be easy but she is definitely can
score a GM norm she already scored and I
am norm and I don't know how you're as
strong as she is ready to where she is
and not have any I am norms I assume
it's an accident somehow but she's
scored on I am norm quite easily bite
she's already over half a point that's
needed for the I am normal tomorrow's
gonna be really
Morrow will be awesome and we'll see how
tato does if topped-up wins then
actually both playing for the GM norm
why don't we actually check out top
tubes again we haven't seen it yet it
looks kind of crazy my guess I think
she's been defending most of this game
so a win will be unlikely however as you
guys can see she should curd this past
beep on white as a past Jeep on it's
really about whose pawn proves to be
stronger one of the reasons I like white
is cuz I feel like more centralized
pieces more centralized King should have
the better of it
however this has gone pretty crazy I
would say anything can still happen this
game I would give him the edge but I
really don't know what exactly is going
on and whether whether he'll be able to
reel him the point as usual of course
neither player has much time at all
he/she has it looks like barely over a
minute he has less than a minute it's
anything can happen in these games so
we'll see what happens let's see if we
can move around elsewhere we talked
about Adi Patel's game now I didn't tell
if he wins he is type of lead with
Barone so however John Bartholomew it
looks like has a pretty active Queen my
guess would be that here Adi is going to
give perpetual meaning it'll be king h1
so I'll move like this check this Queen
is simply way too powerful as we can see
and I have a feeling the game will end a
perpetual right here so Adi will be tied
for second with Stubb Rula well I
believe we're gonna be talking to in
just a minute so that should be good get
her perspective on her win and let's see
going back to Tatas game for the moment
yeah looks like looks like lots of stuff
going on here again I'm not exactly sure
what's going on looks like just kind of
a mess to me but again I think that the
knight and rook a little bit stronger
for whites and this B pawn alone with
the rope probably is not gonna get the
job done
that being said still pretty complicated
not exactly sure what will happen here
but we do have a guest in the studio who
I'd like to talk to we have stavroula
Kito yes something like that you can say
the name for the audience to get it
right I should have been practicing the
last several days what are you gonna be
doing so you won your name
congratulations still in the run for the
GM norm you already clinched your I am
norm so congratulations I didn't even
know I assumed it 2410 I am norms are
you're just achieving them everywhere
you just don't but so why don't you take
us through your game yeah so I liked
your position that I didn't like your
position and then all of a sudden it was
good yeah so opening expected more or
less not at all okay
usually play Sicilian right yeah yeah so
this was a little bit surprising it
doesn't seem like his style but maybe he
wanted to play it solid I don't know we
castle is Queenie - yeah first I thought
this was gonna be a nice quiet game and
then I saw you Castle queenside oh my
god ha not so much yeah yeah so the
knight move c6 this all looked fairly
mean yeah it was also considered net
excitement baby Matty v looked kind of
interesting I thought maybe he could
even ignore it something like there
should be six take I thought you were
just losing too much time yeah yes maybe
I mean also your night your night I
don't know I don't know if I trust you
even a move like c6 and this coming I
don't know it seems like probably I mean
you've have to play c3 it's gonna be
kind of ugly though yeah yeah I don't
know maybe but you could have tried it
it didn't look unplayable but okay 93
yeah I don't know it was very strange I
wasn't sure whose attack was really
stronger in this position I didn't know
made a fire it's a 9 to 5
yeah before g5 yeah so did you expect
him to play with g6 is that force it's
me because if b3 DC so b3 oh you're
gonna play Jesus
uh-huh so this is a b3 trying to mainly
undermine this pawn AMISOM yeah so but
the problem is there's not enough pieces
to really make that many threats here
for him I mean a3 I guess but there's no
like you can't get the Queen stuck like
the Queen needs to be out here thank you
but the Queen is stuck so that makes
things kind of annoying ah g6
it looks kind of nasty I mean mainly
because like if you ever played six of
course you're gonna tacked on yeah and
if you take pink air Bishop back but
this looks I mean this looks so he
decided to play g6 I'm saw a few checks
could you so you couldn't take on f6
first yeah before another take so check
oh no no before take oh yeah so takes so
Queen Esther take even a fixie five I
was thinking yeah cuz we didn't see you
didn't get a chance to look at the
systems before I came on so uh so good
needs but maybe not Queen h5 so the idea
of course is this is the threat so net
afraid so the idea is the Queen's now
defenders so problem is also this is
kind of secure now sighs I'm sure where
your attacks coming from maybe you have
a move like this but it seems like black
can always capture maybe not not quite
enough but this seems kind of
unnecessary like but here is there a
reason why you can't take first and then
play that you for I have to tell you
guys this happens all the time we're
calculating when you're actually
calculating the game as opposed to just
analyzing it casually you can with
anything anything you can miss so I'm
guessing that this would be pretty
right she's really good yeah so the idea
of course is that the Queen's attacked
if you try to counter-attack the Queen
the key is that this rook is hit so this
is what check looks to be quite honest
so this was maybe a possibility yeah cuz
here this pawn actually comes in handy
it kind of gets in the way
Knight G takes h5 yes it was we needed
it looked really strong I didn't think
he would play the way he played I
thought he had to play a couple
defensive moves maybe earlier but then
here the tables really turned on you so
Queen f6 here were you a little worried
were you thinking you weren't sure I
thought you might try a knight back to
c4 followed by trying an e5 type move
but again it didn't look ideal right
this isn't what you want you're not
quite attacking I didn't like once you
gave up the bishop I thought that it was
I actually liked blacks position in a
lot of ways here but you turned it
around so why don't you show us how that
happened rook F fades
yeah okay fade you weren't sure about
like I thought that he would honestly
just play like I mean okay maybe this is
a bit lame but something like take C
even just make six just keep this pawn
and let the bishops kind of do their
work this Knight is very awkward I just
wasn't sure but at the same time if you
can get away with taking stuff and maybe
this pawn becomes weak yeah I don't know
it seemed like I thought that blacks
should be doing well but losing this
pawn was a bit annoying so Bishop here H
for I wasn't quite sure but rook f4
should be six you have no time it's it's
pretty tough to see what to do but it
seems like the problem is that this
Bishop is just not secure you knew all
this tempo and that became a real
problem for blacks oh here I already
thought you were making good kind of
play here I was looking at T so captures
rights chase here so the problem is this
guy is still quite weak here threatening
maids must block takes h4 and you defend
this pawn so maybe this would have been
an interesting try I don't know the C
pawn might become actually kind of
dangerous but for the moment the White
King is a little
a little bit suspicious and that makes
things quite difficult maybe a move
instead of there maybe King c1 as
possible and the idea would be after it
takes maybe you can get away with this
I'm not sure this H pawn could be nasty
but if the King gets into the game you
have a lot of funds I'm not so sure but
again like we were I mean we were trying
to we were basically in the same
situation as you we have no time trying
to figure this out but here I thought
that it was already the Knights were
becoming really hippity-hoppity and
something bad would it would happen to
him actually vision about five was a bit
surprising I thought he might go to d7
but I don't know nothing really looked
that amazing oh so any key moments you
want to point out here or are you just
playing and no I thought you might take
this pawn actually but but this move is
kind of tricky because now we were
showing this that after here you can
just take it and so this was kind of a
nice trick he took this pawn you played
back and the problem is these bishops it
just don't have enough squares the
Knights are dancing around this is weak
this is hit I thought your position here
was actually quite good yeah and still
this pawn is not capturable or is it
that could spoil things ah
so maybe but you don't know you can take
here mimics take you of this fork
although even if even if takes I don't
know yeah even this is not so clear for
you probably you calculated this but
again would you have no time you're just
trying to play your best moves you're
not worrying about everything being
perfect
but he played rook got five and I
thought after I four it just looked
really good five this was probably a key
mistake for him and after this you just
decided look I'm just taking everything
check I saw this position I thought you
might try this move with the idea that
after here Knight here and you of this
so this is still not capturable
yeah maybe so cute I don't know I
thought this looked really funny though
with all these pieces but somehow this
but Bishop c6 then you have Knight a5
you're hitting the bishop again you have
this guy coming yeah I don't know
although the rook the rook hangs you
it's still crazy yeah but what you did
seemed to work out very simply no
unnecessary stuff you go after the
b-pawn and the tactics just don't seem
to work for black if you take hero a c6
if Brook f1 always routes you one so
Bishop went back and it's funny you
don't usually see a position with the
Knights dominate the bishops but it
seems like when they're escorted by all
these pawns that's exactly what happened
I didn't get to see much of this and I
should point out to the viewers you're
not offering a draw you're just trying
to play moves to make time control so
you get the pawns rolling and yeah h1
looked kind of nasty but you're Yvonne
is really strong and the bishops just
can't defend that well so rook h2 Bishop
takes c5 King back yeah I thought that
you have lots of goods can things I
thought you'd play Knight d7 you played
in 84 which is also quite strong the
idea of course as it takes you give this
check and you want 96 so he sacks but
this is just too strong and then the
nice finishing move rook f2 and I party
a pointed this out to people that this
check is quite strong so you move up you
recover from a tough loss last night so
yeah and yeah cuz I thought you were
probably headed towards the draw but
your pieces got a little tangled but so
you're now you know still in the running
a jam norm with a win in the last round
you play top Fe and I thought it would
be maybe that you chose are the leaders
of the tournament playing in the last
round actually if she wins her game
she's still playing no oh she lost so so
she's no longer playing for a GM norm
yeah it looks like well that's kind of
nasty so the idea here of course is that
this guy can't move because the Queen if
the knight moves back then you just
check here and this one Queen so I guess
Tata did lose her game but you know
still all to play for in the last round
what are your thoughts going into the
last round you're still kind of a shark
okay I understand
cool yesterday's game yeah I think a
blunder yeah I mean I thought you were
trying to win I thought at some point
maybe you can play g5 in that position
but yeah but okay I mean still remember
the exact moment that's what happens but
wait for the Whelan but it's not so easy
to do things can easily work against you
but you recovered from both your losses
this tournament pretty well and you're
in good shape you are still not in the
lead of the tournament I believe Pablo
Vorontsov is still in the lead you're
tied for second but obviously you're
playing for your norm I think you have
the black pieces in the last wrong I'm
black pieces so you're gonna just go
crazy trying to win are you gonna beat
play solitaire you know work in the
screen somewhere in between well
congratulations on your I am the best of
luck in the last run for your GM though
thanks Ron rights why don't we'll take a
break we'll be right back
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
[Music]
you could fly to Venice
[Music]
or Paris or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world but why
when you had just come to st. Louis your
trip begins at explore st. Louis calm
hi mike matheny well you play chess for
fun or want to boost your child's
academic performance come visit the
Chess Club and scholastic Center of st.
Louis right here in the chest capital of
the u.s. from a welcoming diverse
environment to a Scholastic outreach
program now in over 100 schools our
Center across from the world chess Hall
of Fame the Central West End has it all
so whether you've played for years or
never before we invite you to experience
all chess has to offer
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
vacation we're back with the st. Louis
norm Congress where we are just having
fun
infinity plus of time I've been Simon
along with Grandmaster Josh Frieda
an ultimate round has officially ended
all games have completed and we're
looking to get another player in here to
talk to him about their game well what
did we miss the last few minutes here
Josh uh well as I mentioned at the end
of the interview with stavroula Tata did
lose her game against hammer cool off so
she is out of norm contention however
she's still having an excellent
tournament a lot to play for her
mccoullough of recovering from sort of a
rough result so he's getting back in
there but as you can see there's no
stability if you're leading you could be
losing the next day if you're in last
place you could be winning the next day
so really anything can happen but she is
out of norm contention John Bartholomew
drew against Advaita Patel Adi Patel and
neither of these players now are in norm
contention either that game ended as I
predicted in a perpetual in this
position the white Queens simply too
strong on f7 threatening to take the
world and probably checkmate so ad you
decided you know what I'm gonna just
keep checking your king
so all the games in all the sections are
done as we mentioned another game Carlos
Torres did win again his black against
Aaron Grove in ski so he recovers from
his triple 0 result as I predicted he
did Queen that'd be pond and upper rook
is just too much and other results that
we missed
Brandon Jacobson had an advantage
against she usual both players not
really in contention for anything but
I'll tell you what you're always trying
to fight in these tournaments you don't
want if no one wants to finish last
place and right now she use and last but
she could have lost but she defended
well finally secured to draw in this
Queen onion so why don't we take a quick
look at the standings yes please let's
do so in the top section Verone stove
maintains the lead with five and a half
addy Patel most of ruler soloqueue
are chasing with five note how stavroula
is chasing a norm because six will get
her a norm addy unfortunately cannot
score Norma six he needed six and a half
so there's only one norm seeker here but
as we can see everyone's playing for
first place John Bartholomew in fourth
place has a very outside chance but
really it's gonna be first place between
those three players we'll see what
happens I look forward to it well and
also remember there are no playoffs so
there could be a situation where we do
have more than one first-place winner
indeed I should point out the touch of a
bra immune if she gets four and a half
will secure it I am knew him she already
has about 60 so she doesn't actually
need it but I feel like I should mention
it why not you know so why don't we
check out the standings for the I am
norm see what's happening there first
place is secure sir game at Cinco wins
the I am norm section with six and a
half points point and a half ahead of
Josh colas Josh colas needs a win in the
last round to secure his I am norm but
having an excellent result huge pack of
fours that's a lot of fours Ben is
that's what you call a log jam right
there but it's quite frankly irrelevant
with Matt psycho at being the champion
of this section it is and none of those
players can score enormous but believe
me everyone's trying to get
result it's much nicer to walk away from
the tournament I've had tournaments
where I play horribly but if I win that
last round I walk away feeling all right
about myself so I would say that every
player there is still gonna have some
incentive to walk away from the last
round with the win and this is affecting
the the prize money in a little business
in a unique way because even though we
have many players who cannot norm
anymore
there are prizes to be won and in fact
for for both fields 6 through 10th is
the same amount for both fields and
there you see the Grandmaster section
prize fund see 6 through 10 everybody
walks away with as you said it not
enough to pay their expense to pay their
expenses maybe a little bit extra you
know depending but the point is that you
know 600 700 800 then it's not a big
difference but people really just want
to finish well you know we finishing 4th
in the tournament this strong is not a
bad result for most players so as you
can see it's not just about the prizes
those kind of compensate you but it's
really about just it's nice to finish
higher in the exactly the International
Master norms section their prize fund it
works the same way if there is a tie for
a placing what they do is they let's say
that third and fourth place is tied they
would add up the prizes okay so you get
1300 split it six hundred fifty dollars
each so they just add up the prizes and
just split it six through ten tie well
it's all four hundred anyway so yeah
won't matter too much but yes you add up
all the prizes and then divide them but
again I think the difference between one
hundred one hundred fifty dollars fifty
dollars for these players not a huge
difference it's more about do it getting
that nice finish
I noticed that stavroula so lucky D so
lucky do rather all right no no I was
gonna she wasn't really showing her
cards as to whether she was going to be
playing for a win tomorrow would you be
if you were of course not but I always
like to ask just in case sometimes
people are like you know what I'm gonna
go crazy I'm gonna be an animal tomorrow
I'm gonna start out with H 5 H 4 I'm the
first five moves I don't you don't
really expect that most people give a
pretty moderated answer anyway but I
thought it's always good to ask cuz you
don't really know what people do some
people just place all
and see if their opponent gives them
chances other people play more
aggressively I don't think that's two
rulers the type of player who just play
solid anyway she she seems pretty
aggressive don't want the two equal
positions she had something crazy
happened last night she didn't equal
position and lost honestly I don't think
that that's in her blood to to play it's
just completely safe anyway I think
we'll just see an interesting game
taught them of course very aggressive
player so why don't we actually check
out the pairings for the last rounds so
we can see what we're looking at
uniquely important and actually remember
this is not gonna be tonight this is
tomorrow today's round got its own game
tomorrow live its own day as well
indeed so for those of you tuning in at
5 p.m. for the last round you're gonna
be supremely disappointed I would
recommend turning in at 11:00 tomorrow
of course we'll be on at 2:00 talking
about the last games so we have again
Tata of abraham yun against surrealist
so Loki who is a key game not just for
first place obviously if ster ruler wins
she has a shot at that but a win will
get her a GM norm as well and also we
have the tournament leader pavlova on
sub as white against Akshay Chandra shot
has been playing not his best chess he's
lost a couple is Verano of gonna secure
his tournament victory it seems quite
possible but we'll have to see and Adi
Patel also in tied for second place
can't get his norm but he's shooting for
first two as white against Harmon Akula
of who scored a nice win for him today
against Tata and then the final round
pairings for the International master
norm section tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. here
from st. Louis you can see this on US
chess champs calm indeed josh colas is
the only one still playing for a norm as
black against Brandon Jacobson I would
say that josh will really try to win
this game Jacobsen if you recall started
out Owen for but he scored a win in the
fifth round he's recovered somewhat the
last several rounds he's done pretty
well he drew today maybe dis lightly
disappointingly but he's not longer in
the basement he's no longer in the
cellar
it won't I don't think it'll be an easy
game for Josh but I think he has
excellent chances to score that norm
otherwise Mott Cinco we get to see him
against the 12 year old Justin wing and
that should be quite an interesting one
but Matt Sanko has already secured first
place he won't do anything crazy but
we'll definitely see some nice games
tomorrow
I can't wait it's gonna be very exciting
Josh Andy and we hope that you join us
tomorrow at 2 p.m. and even catch it a
little bit earlier because remember the
round starts at 11 a.m. Central we'll
see you at 2:00 p.m. at us chest champs
calm today's show was produced by the
world's greatest B team our technical
advisor is Tammy hide our graphics and
sound man is Isaac's fronts Danny
Machuca is our technical director and
for Grand Master Josh Vidal I'm Ben
Simon we'll see you tomorrow and until
then so long from the Show Me State
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you